الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا يعد احد
اكثر الزلازل تسببا في وقوع ضحايا خلال
السنوات العشر الاخيره عوامل كثيره وقفت
خلف هذا الزلزال وجعلته مميتا بينها طبعا
قربه من سطح الارض لا يمكن مشاهدينا
التنبؤ بالزلزال قبل حدوثه لاجل ذلك يصعب
تفادي تداعياته الخطيره والتي تكون احيانا
مدمره حسب قوه الزلزال بمقياس رختر لنلقي
معا نظره عامه حول كيفيه حصول الزلزال
يعرف الزلزال بانه اهتزاز ارضي مفاجئ ينتج
عن الحركه المستمره للصفائح التكتونيه
والتي تسبب تراكم الضغط على طبقات الصخور
على جانبي الصعود صدوع الواقعه بين
الصفائح مما يؤدي طبعا الى تكسر الكتل
الصخريه وانزلاقها وبالتالي اطلاق الطاقه
المخزنه في القشره الارضيه في حركه مفاجئه
ينتج عن موجات تحمل طاقه زلزاليه تنتشر
عبر صخور الارض لتصل الى السطح كما نشاهد
هنا مما يتسبب طبعا بحدوث الاهتزازات
تتعدد الاسباب الطبيعيه لحصول الزلازل
لتشمل الزلزال التكتوني التي تعد الاكثر
شيوعا وهنا يحدث انجراف قاري وتوسع في قاع
المحيط لينقسم الى عدد من الاجزاء او
الصفائح الصلبه التي تتراوح سمكتها بين
مئه ومئه وخمسين كيلومتر لتتحرك بعدها فوق
طبقه الغلاف المري التي تقع تحت قشره
الارض مباشره هناك ايضا الزلزال الزلازل
البركانيه التي تحدث بسبب البراكين
الناشطه ولكنها ليست بقوه الزلازل
التكتونيه غالبا ما تحدث بالقرب من سطح
الارض ولذلك يتم الشعور بها فقط بالقرب من
نقطه منشا الزلزال يعقب حدوث الزلازل
العديد من الاحداث والاثار التي قد تكون
مدمره ويمكن ان تتخذ اشكالا متعدده منها
الانهيارات والفيضانات والحرائق
والسيول والتربه والسونامي
[موسيقى]